she's actually really good i think just
the fact that the ankle tag has come off
that she was able to go and visit some
friends to visit her granny to
um go and visit her sister and just to
be able to
breathe a bit and go around the city and
just have a social life
after a year of an ankle tag but also
four years of prison
um that's no small thing so she was
actually i mean you can see there's a
big grin on her face there
there was a big grin every time we spoke
to her big grin on her mum's face and
her dad's face and and
yesterday she was just enjoying the fact
that okay she's out and it's moved
forwards for her
um as you say there is a second court
case
that that was handed down to her in fact
um
you know before they took the ankle tag
off hello i got the telephone call and
said listen you're going to be uh
in courtney on sunday and and the ankle
tag only came off at the very end of
yesterday
so um but the embassy british embassy in
tehran had
really issued a notable like a formal
warning saying listen it's the end of
the sentence
you've not released her i think that's
what triggered it for it to come off so
if there's clearly uncertainty that
potentially she's home soon potentially
she's got another sentence and
years or months or years even to go we
remain in this kind of structural
uncertainty that's part of the game
that's been played all along
so um i think we enjoyed yesterday and
she's still quite cheerful this morning
and as sunday gets closer then start to
build up the
foreboding again um so richard just in
terms of this
next court date that is now hanging
hanging over all of you
exactly what does it does it relate to
and and
i think you just said a second ago but
correct me if i'm wrong
this was the first time that you'd heard
about this potential
legal action was when the lawyer was
spoken to yeah just at the weekend
so yes or no is the short answer um it
was the lawyer got called and said
you're going to be in court on
on on sunday um it is the court action
that was happening in november it's the
court action that
was happening back in autumn 2017 and
that got blamed at one point on the
prime minister
um and we'll see what happens in court i
i don't have a clear feeling at this
point
whether it's more political stunt or
more like a threat to the british
government to say listen if you don't
move in the ways you need to
you can still do bad stuff or if
substantively it really is there to
to to put the descendants down um
certainly said uh you know you should
prepare yourself for a conviction
um but but we'll see what comes
what assistance um did what information
is is reaching you from the people who
are not
not a mile away from where i'm standing
at the moment we of course have had
condemnation
of the decision taken by iranian
authorities from both the foreign
secretary
and the prime minister i'm wondering
what what other information they might
be passing you through other channels
yeah no no rightly i'm pleased that they
were as strong as they were on their
statements and behind closed doors we've
asked them to be you know stronger for a
long time
um i don't think around it moves through
through you know warming words but
through clarity um behind look i don't
think the foreign officers got a
clear feel for what's actually happening
they clearly talk closely
at the moment with the iranian foreign
ministry the iranian following ministry
is not in control of what happens in
nazarene's case because that's the
revolution regard
um and the judiciary and they don't
always talk in the same
same same words so you know over the
weekend
i was in reasonable touch with the
foreign office um line team
last week i met the foreign secretary
actually twice to talk through what was
going on and and
he said to me that he felt that he was
close it was closer than it had been for
a long time um but there are no
guarantees
i think that's what we're seeing now is
it's moved one step closer
and there's the threat maybe the reality
of one or two steps back
and it's so often of hope's been raised
that i suspect that for you and for the
for
the broader family you want to try and
avoid that but but it must be difficult
to have
come to the end of that sentence and for
the potential of more jail time to be
uh to be coming nazdan's way i mean how
much of this is still
to do with those historic reparations
that iran has been calling for for for
many a year
well my personal view is everything um i
think that's why nazim was taken i think
that's why
um every sort of strange thing that's
happened in our case can normally be
linked
to something that's happening with that
debt um clearly the british government
doesn't want to make the linkage
um and you know rightly doesn't want to
incentivize hostage taking
um but iran does practice hostage
diplomacy it does take people for
leverage
that's openly acknowledged by the
government um what that means well we
don't get to see where the negotiations
are
on that debt dispute um we can only hope
it gets solved
sooner so that it's not just nazim but
nothing and others
are able to come home